we begin this hour with the uptick in
covid cases in the u.s and abroad cases
here surged more than 50 percent in the
past two weeks and hospitalizations are
up eight percent throughout the pandemic
the uk has consistently been a harbinger
of what's to come in the united states
when britain dropped its covet
restrictions in late february coveted
cases hospitalizations and deaths soared
and may have only recently peaked chris
van cleave has been digging into the
numbers
[Music]
across london life looks a lot like it
did before the pandemic and coveted
restrictions are gone how often do you
see somebody getting in your cab with a
mask
not very often at all
most of them are now just
taking them ourselves and kept them off
london cabbie ken allen is still taking
precautions including keeping windows
open but masking is now a commuter's
choice i just feel a bit safer
especially when i'm on public transport
and i'm indoors like in a shop i still
wear a mask i don't think it should be
you can't get a bus if you don't wear
one were you happy to see the mandate go
away here
well yes and no i mean of course it
comes with risk especially as someone
who doesn't have kovid i do feel
uncomfortable sometimes when sitting
next to someone who's coughing without a
mask
in late february a new covet strategy
saw the uk's restrictions lifted so let
us learn
to live with this virus
and continue protecting ourselves and
others without restricting our freedoms
similar to right now in the u.s mass
mandates on mass transit and british
airlines ended just as cases started to
surge driven by the ba2 subvariant daily
cases jumped 435 percent in three weeks
after the decision to unmask
deaths more than doubled even his
testing plummeted across england last
week it's estimated one in every 17
people had covet do you think relaxing
the mask rules particularly on planes
and trains and buses was a mistake yeah
i think it is a mistake
once you remove the face mask mandate
people will start to behave in a much
more liberal way
as if the virus doesn't exist as if
there's no need to be cautious professor
lawrence young is a virologist at the
university of warwick the virus isn't
over with us
he expects the u.s will see a spike
similar to the uk
essentially taking your foot off the
brake
to all at once is inevitably resulting
in high levels of infection so by saying
you don't need to wear a mask you're
telling people
they don't need to worry anymore yeah i
think that's exactly right that somehow
we could return to a pre-pandemic world
where kobe doesn't exist and sadly
that's not the case
this latest covet surge appears to have
peaked here but still well over 200
people a day on average are dying from
the virus one big difference between the
uk and the u.s vaccination rates more
brits have been fully vaccinated and far
more have received a booster shot
for cbs saturday morning i'm chris van
cleeve in london
very interesting traveling yesterday
with all the developments that happened
this week i would say inside airports
five to ten percent of people had mass
on on the plane it was more probably 30
percent i would say got to make your
choice yeah
it's a crap shoot i almost didn't get
into the country i was heading into
because they had such tight restrictions
so it's kind of still all over the place
yeah different in every place yeah